MSP for Edinburgh Eastern s p leadership
candidate Ash Regan thank you so much
for being on the program
what's your position on Gary lineker
then
sorry can you repeat that Sophie what's
your position on Gary lineker
yes I was asked this the other night
actually and I hadn't seen his tweets
um but yeah I think the way he's been
treated
um is pretty terrible actually he should
be allowed to express his views and I
think morally what's going on at the
moment with the conservatives and their
position on this
um is morally reprehensible
strong words there on the row over that
Gary lindika tweet well look I'm very
keen to talk about your own pitch right
you want to be the next leader of the s
p you want to be the next first Minister
what is the big idea
well as you can understand
um the membership of the SNP are very
concerned about the the way that the UK
gov the UK is going if you think about
what we're facing at the moment we've
got skyrocketing energy costs because of
the conservative mismanagement of the
economy inflation is making everything
much more expensive for families you
know including food and we were dragged
out of the EU against our will which is
having a disproportionate impact on the
Scottish economy so things are looking
difficult at the moment up here and I
think it's entirely right to be able to
look at this question again of
Independence and that is something that
obviously the members of the s p are
very interested in when and how would we
be able to get to an independent
Scotland
well that's the question isn't it you
know you launched your campaign with the
slogan Independence nothing less but the
government of Westminster have refused
to Grant referendum so how do you get
there
they have and that is obviously within
their gift to refuse a referendum and if
you think about it the reason that they
are refusing a referendum is because
they don't want to allow Scotland to
express its Democratic will at the ball
The Ballot Box but what we need to
remember here is that not many countries
achieve their independence through
referendums actually that's fairly
unusual and actually it's much more
normal to use a scheduled election to
use The Ballot Box in order for the
people to express their will
you know the problem is though if you
know you say you you'd use a election as
a de facto referendum but but who are
you to say that people are only voting
on Independence you know they might
think the S P's got the best policy on
the cost of living they might think that
you ashrigan have got the best policy
when it comes to the gender recognition
act and that's not how the Westminster
government would say either is it
so the the facto referendum is a
different it's a similar um strategy but
it's a different strategy the de facto
referendum is is for on a single
occasion on a single issue and you're
quite right to point out that at the
moment with the things that are going on
right now energy crisis cost of living
crisis problems in the NHS across the UK
you know the public will quite rightly
um not want to fight a single issue
um de facto referendum so that's not
what I'm suggesting what I'm suggesting
is the voter empowerment mechanism and
this sets up a permanent mechanism to
run each and every election in Scotland
as an opportunity for the people of
Scotland to express their will over
whether they want to govern themselves
so the trigger point for that would be
50 plus one and that is a strategy that
used to be widely accepted this was an
SNP policy up until about
um the year 2000 it was previously
accepted by the conservatives in
Westminster Margaret Thatcher herself
had said all this policy years ago that
this was perfectly Democratic and it was
a legitimate way and for the Scottish
people to express their will so I'm
under I expect that the UK government
would understand that Democratic mandate
if that was expressed by the people of
Scotland and that they would recognize
it they often start off saying no but
then they always come to the table and
eventually say yes okay uh we'll have to
see on that one now I hope this doesn't
sound too harsh but you have got an
absolute mountain to climb uh in this
leadership competition a recent ipsos
Scotland poll found 32 saying Kate
Forbes would make the best first
Minister Hunter Yusuf was on 24 you're
on eight percent
if you don't win who are you going to
endorse
I'm in this competition to win it I've
been having a lot of support expressed
to me by the membership we have to
remember it's it's fairly difficult I
think to get an accurate idea of what
the s p membership are thinking at the
moment we understand that there's a
large amount of membership that are
still undecided um it's a very short
contest so it's certainly true to say
um that I am probably the least well
known out of the candidates and with
less name and recognition
um and it is an opportunity for me to
work that bit harder to set out my stall
if you like on what I'm proposing to do
um but I have had many people get in
touch with me recently to say that they
think that I am the only hope for the
SMP we are at Crossroads at the moment
in terms of where we go next and I
believe I'm the candidate that is
setting out a credible Democratic means
for Scotland to express its will at
about box and give Scotland that choice
over their own future
I thought it was interesting to hear
that you said you say that you think
it's a conflict of interest that Peter
Morrow Nicole sturgeon's husband to
remain as the s p chief executive while
this leadership contest is going along I
mean he doesn't have a role in the
ballot why do you think that
well effectively he's running the
contest to
um replace
um his wife and I think if we think of
that in a different way you know that
would be like Carrie counting the votes
for boris's successor and I think many
people would think that that would be
fairly unusual I think there is a
conflict of interest here my campaign
team we've set out that we think it
should be an independent third party
company that should be running the
contest and that we've also asked for
there to be a neutral Observer as well
just to make sure everything is above
board we need to be careful in this too
and we're the largest party in Scotland
and the person that wins this contest
will not just be leader of the SNP but
they'll actually also become the first
minister of the country this is very
significant it's very important and it's
important for both the members of the
SNP but also the wider country that
there's trust in this process that it's
all above board and it's transparent
now you disagreed with Nicola sturgeon
over the gender recognition Reform Bill
you resigned from government so you
could vote against it Nicholas station
said you didn't approach her with your
concerns is that true
um I did have many conversations inside
government with special advisors I
raised this issue in 2019 at cabinet
with Nicholas sturgeon so My Views
inside government were well known on on
this issue
so she's not really being honest in your
opinion then
well as I said I also signed an open
letter with many of my colleagues in
2019 to the newspapers so I don't think
it's credible to say that my views were
not well known okay now just finally you
said earlier on the interview that you
were the least well known candidate in
the competition so I thought we'd do
something about that with a couple of
quick fun questions to end
um ready
here's your political hero
I don't really have one I admire many
people who've made big social changes
but um there's certainly not anyone in
in the recent history that I I would
name particularly
ever broken the law
um not that I can remember no
definitely
sorry guilty pleasure
guilty pleasure um watching a very
lightweight television when I'm tired
come one example Give an example I'm
terrible on this stuff as well so no
judgment here
um Bridgerton or something like that a
guilty pleasure
and what's your greatest achievement
well I was I was very proud actually of
being able to stand up in the Scottish
Parliament
you know um with a very small number of
people actually and make the case for
the fact that there was a conflict of
rights under the gender recognition
Reform Bill
um there was a great sense I think in
Scotland that many the voices of women
particularly hadn't been heard during
this process and so I was proud to give
voice to that during the stage three
debate and raise those issues that women
had expressed to me and make make that
case in public for them and speak for
them
okay thank you very much for being on
the program uh good to have you on one
of the first series of debates we're
doing of interviews shall I say that
we're doing with the leadership
candidates thank you